you'll like this next episode they talk
about your people
my
people
chinese australians
these are vietnamese americans oh i got
confused because of the
slanty
eyes oh
wow
it's different if i'm drawing myself i
changed my logo anyway
who drew these
oh lord
not so pretty is a hbo documentary
series about supposedly dangerous beauty
products it's a very persuasive sleek
looking documentary a lot of people
chucked out their products after
watching it and as someone who breaks
into bottles to use the last three drops
at the bottom this cut me deep i'm
michelle of lab of beauty science i'm a
chemistry phd and cosmetic chemist and i
care about my health which is why i've
gone through the research on a lot of
the ingredients that clean beauty
documentaries talk about and that's why
i know they usually talk about them
incorrectly last time i talked about
episode 1 makeup which was about
asbestos and talc this time we're
talking about nails like and subscribe
if you like nerding out about the
science behind beauty products this
episode focuses on health problems in
nail salon workers a lot of them are
vietnamese immigrants people had
tremendous respiratory health issues
miscarriages and pregnancy complications
the skin coming off and breast cancer
they talked to people working in the
nail industry and researchers studying
these health problems they talk about
how activists have tried to improve the
situation and what they recommend
consumers do i have less issues with
this episode i still have issues because
it does use a lot of the same not
entirely transparent techniques that we
saw in episode one documentaries aren't
science and to me this is very much a
problem with not so pretty documentaries
don't need to carefully go through all
the data or try to be objective they
just need to tell a good story and a lot
of the time science is
not that science usually doesn't have
easy clear-cut answers and it's a
gradual process of building evidence
there are very few exciting bombshells
so documentaries end up doing a lot of
cherry picking they carefully choose
little bits of data to build a good
story which doesn't necessarily match
what the science actually says
in the talc episode they highlighted two
brands that had asbestos in their
products and this was used to suggest
that all products with talc were
dangerous even though there's good
evidence that's not the case
they left that out they highlighted two
people with mesothelioma who used chao
products and had some lawyers who were
suing companies over talc basically just
present their side of the court case
they didn't mention there's no real
evidence that tao caused their
mesothelioma or that the chance of
getting mesothelioma from makeup is just
incredibly low so they really gave a
skewed perspective on the reality of the
risks and what we should be doing to
reduce these risks this now episode is
one of the better ones probably because
they actually got relevant experts this
time but they do still distort a lot of
the issues and they pull out some pretty
questionable conclusions
first off they do mention a great point
less privileged groups tend to have less
scientific research done on them nothing
had been done to understand what the
exposures and health impacts are for the
workers people who work in industries
like nail salons are poor people people
of color many immigrants the majority
are women and so they tend to get less
attention from scientists this is a huge
problem in science that's been widely
recognized for a long time studies are
done a lot more on white cis men for a
bunch of reasons not just sexism or
racism although there is a lot of that
just one example if there's any chance
that someone in your experiment could be
pregnant you have to thoroughly check
that they're not because harming an
unborn child for science is a really bad
look so logistically it's easier and
cheaper to study subjects without this
extra complexity the problem is what
happens in white cis men isn't always
the same as what happens in everyone
else
and that means that you often end up
with worse treatments and outcomes for
other groups because of that lack of
information
sometimes healthcare providers will even
dismiss health problems as all in your
head because that health problem just
hasn't been researched enough so there's
no official evidence that it's an issue
there are lots of efforts to try to fix
these imbalances but it's a very long
process
and this whole mess is partly why the
clean beauty narrative that beauty
products caused your health problems is
so effective for women and people of
color the way that black people and
people of color are treated when they do
try to seek treatment they don't get
taken seriously so i think that's it
leads us to you know try to seek an
answer try to find our own answers which
is not really
a solution um in my opinion and it's
really sad and i think that you know
when people see documentaries like this
they think you know they finally found
an answer is giving us the answers that
we've been looking for all the time you
know they don't consider the other
factors this episode features dr true
kwach an epidemiologist who started
researching health problems in nail
salon workers around 2008. they talk
about one of her findings and here's
where it gets misleading dr kwach
continued her research and found that
vietnamese manicurists have a nearly 40
increase in risk of having babies that
are small for gestational age but if you
look at the paper they show you can see
the rest of the paragraph that they've
cropped out it actually starts with
there was little evidence of increased
risk for adverse birth outcomes
babies small for gestational age is one
of the few issues that's been linked to
working in nail salons but the
documentary mentions all sorts of health
problems miscarriages birth defects
breast cancer it lumps all of these
together generalizing them like they all
have the same amount of evidence they
don't mention that one of dr quartz's
other studies found that nail salon
workers had a lower rate of cancer than
average
and i'm not saying that these other
health problems aren't linked to nail
salons my gut feeling is that some more
will eventually be linked there needs to
be more research but i think it's really
misleading how they make a seem like all
these links have already been discovered
by cherry picking half a sentence from
one study and only showing us that
so there isn't that much research
showing higher rates of these health
problems in nail salon workers
but there is evidence that they're
exposed to much higher amounts of
potentially harmful substances than
average that's why i think more health
links will be found and salon workers
need more protections i'm pretty sure
most scientists would agree but the
problem not so pretty has is that it
really clings to clean beauty logic that
ingredients can be neatly divided into
good and bad and once you take out the
bad toxic ingredients now salon workers
won't have any more health problems
this isn't how it works that's not how
any of this works how dangerous an
ingredient is depends on how you're
exposed to it
the most important issue is dose
if you're exposed to more of something
you're more likely to be harmed by it
and if you have enough of a relatively
safe thing it can still be harmful
this is commonly referred to as the dose
makes the poison and this episode of not
so pretty actually shows how ignoring
exposure is a massive problem there's
this kind of hilarious moment where they
dismiss a nail scientist talking about
how important exposure is just because
because something could cause cancer
does not mean it will cause cancer first
exposure must be high enough and
exposure must occur for long enough or
cancer is a pretty unlikely outcome
hmm
should we take the word of this paid
industry spokesman
let's see what the science has to say
and then they cut to dr lupita montoya
an aerosol scientist and talk about her
research on nail salons which is all
about measuring exposure like there is
zero point during the work she's done
measuring the levels of different gases
and nail salons if you don't think the
amount actually matters and the
documentary says that one minute later
dr montoya measured the levels of
chemicals in the air and nail salons she
found that nail workers were regularly
exposed to chemicals at levels that
would significantly increase the workers
risk of developing cancer in their
lifetime so it's all about the levels
but then after talking about this the
documentary goes straight back to
ignoring exposure again both salon
workers and their customers are
breathing these chemicals and it's been
reported in the media that nail products
have other hidden risks for consumers
which is really silly a salon worker
breathing fumes eight hours a day most
days of the week will have so much more
exposure and very different health
impacts compared to someone getting a
weekly manicure making the true
situation sound the same is really
ridiculous i think we all know this if
you smell strong paint fumes for too
long you get a headache if there's less
or if it's a short amount of time then
you're fine that's why dr montoya
calculated that salon workers would have
a higher risk of cancer than average
that's why dr quartz was looking for
differences between salon workers and
other people but making it seem like the
risk is the same is very handy because
salon workers are getting exposed to
harmful amounts of chemicals is not
going to be as viral as
nail polish is giving us all cancer
so as you'd expect from how they keep
forgetting that exposure is a thing and
their giant list of clean beauty
partners
their solution to all of these issues is
clean beauty just take out the so-called
toxic ingredients from products every
episode of not so pretty ends with a
list of do's and don'ts this time they
tell us to
avoid specific ingredients and nail
polish
tell our salon to avoid them too keep
getting our nails done and ask
politicians to pass laws that mostly
just take out specific ingredients from
products the laws were partly designed
by their clean beauty partners
and this is super frustrating because
removing the ingredients they list
isn't going to solve a lot of the
problems i'll probably do a video going
into 10 free nail polish at some point
because i've read so much bs while
researching this if we focus
specifically on the safety of salon
workers
out of the 16 different ingredient
groups they have seven don't have a
function in nail polish
two don't really have any serious health
impacts apart from skin irritation tphp
isn't inhaled it absorbs through skin
so it's not a big issue if you're doing
someone else's nails so there are only
six that are somewhat relevant there's
evidence that dibeto phthalate toluene
and xylene are probably not that great
for you if you have too much but they
haven't been in the vast majority of
nail polishes for a long time xylene
hasn't been a nail polish since the 90s
i tried to buy a nail polish with gbp
and toluene on the label back in 2012
when i used to be a now blogger check
out my nail art
and they weren't even in the two dollar
bargain bin polishes i had to go on ebay
salons could be buying salon only
products that have these the fact that
salon products don't need to disclose
their ingredients is actually a
legitimate issue that the documentary
talks about formaldehyde is a serious
problem for salon workers but it's a
nail hardness gels and acrylics not
usually nail polish and it comes from
non-nail things too formaldehyde resin
sometimes has leftover unreactive
formaldehyde in it but it has a lot less
so it's mostly a problem for people who
are actually allergic to formaldehyde if
they get the nail polish on their skin
dhp isn't absorbed through skin it's
mostly an issue if you eat it salon
workers aren't licking people's
fingernails unless it's a
very special sort of salon
but maybe tiny amounts inhaled over a
very long time could be an issue so the
hit rate with this list isn't looking
great but more importantly this clean
beauty approach of banning ingredients
misses a lot of the known problems first
off in dr montoya's study that they
showed there were similar levels of
benzene and formaldehyde in a non-toxic
salon as other salons it could be
because nail polishes especially from
smaller brands sometimes have
ingredients in them that aren't on the
label it's already illegal to have an
incorrect ingredients list but as i said
for episode 1 the problem usually isn't
that there aren't laws it's that there
aren't enough resources to monitor
products and enforce the laws that are
already there it could also be that
furniture carpets building materials are
releasing chemicals like formaldehyde
the levels they measured in salons have
also been measured in homes and
preschools the study also found mma in
colorado nail salons even though it's
been banned there it's an ingredient
used in acrylic nails and it turns out
that some salon workers were requesting
it over the safer alternative because it
was easier to apply let me just repeat
this is all from the study that they
actually showed us in the episode
secondly even substances that are
relatively safe can still be nasty if
you're breathing in lots of it all the
time for example acetone is in lots of
nail polish removers and it isn't
considered dirty you actually make it
inside your body but if you breathe in a
lot for a long time it's linked to some
of the health issues that they mentioned
in the documentary like headaches
dizziness and breathing problems and
there are a whole bunch of so called
clean ingredients just like this
and maybe the most bizarre thing is that
there is actually a solution that solves
a lot of these issues that the
documentary barely mentions
cleaning the air inside nail salons if
you actually look at the studies on nail
workers some of them do suggest taking
specific ingredients out of products but
practically all of them say to tackle
the air
since the main problem is that workers
are breathing in high levels of lots of
chemicals the most obvious method is to
improve ventilation having better
airflow will dilute all of the harmful
chemicals that salon workers are
breathing in this includes dirty
ingredients in the nail products but
also safe ingredients and harmful levels
chemicals coming from the furniture and
the building
ingredients that aren't listed on the
labels ingredients that haven't been
researched enough yet there are laws in
some states that require a certain level
of ventilation
although they can be a bit vague and
enforcement is
as always a bit spotty it's also a
requirement to be recognized as a
healthy nail salon in california this
initiative was started by some of the
activists they featured but ventilation
isn't mentioned in their do's and don'ts
maybe it's buried deep in the safer
beauty bills package
but even the act that's meant to protect
salon workers is all about specific
chemicals it does get manufacturers to
add ingredient lists to salon products
and translate safety data to other
languages
which is good but it still doesn't
tackle a lot of the issues and
ventilation does actually come up a few
times in the episode but
they kind of just brush past it news
reports have covered workers speaking
out for better working conditions
demanding better ventilation ppe
equipment and a 15 an hour minimum wage
and one action item they could have
easily added would be to ask your salon
to look at the healthy nail salon
guidelines and put them in place people
who contributed to these guidelines are
featured in the episode these guidelines
are pretty detailed they have sections
on ventilation and protective equipment
and they do have a list of ingredients
not to use but they take into account
exposure so for example ethyl acetate
which is clean
can't be used for removing nail polish
which is when workers would breathe more
in
but they can be used within nail polish
and i'm also wondering why something
like a nationwide healthy salons program
didn't make it into the safer beauty
bills package so to me it seems like
this series and their partners
really go out of their way to promote
clean beauty to the point where they
purposely ignore things the people they
feature recommend and just focus on
clean versus dirty ingredients i'll be
looking at episode 3 on skincare soon
subscribe and click the notification
bell for that also hit the like and
leave me a comment if you found this
video useful also check out my breakdown
of episode one if you want to check out
a bunch of cosmetic chemists including
me talking about the series links are in
the description